i want to start with commending
universal on the amazing matte painting
behind you thank you this green screen i
mean you just it's as if you're in malta
right right it's almost as if and what
people do not realize is you made this
movie in the heart of kovid yes and so
this is literally your first time in
malta even though you were in a sequence
that took place in malta yes yeah we
both
have some of our best action taking
place yeah in malta
and yet yeah it's kayla's world and this
is my first time
literally i mean but also you know as
i've been saying it's just a testament
to kevin our like amazing crew for
replicating that on the sound stage you
know
because i it's just being here i'm like
didn't he did he is that the same brick
like it's really very familiar it feels
very familiar watching the movie you
would never know the movie magic now
it's crazy yeah absolutely so listen i
think that the extended cut is
how can i say this it's it's the
superior version of the film it really
adds so much to it it's the original
version it's the other movie the
original kind of thing right so what are
you most excited for audiences to
actually see in the extended cut well
there's a lot of connective tissue
that is very important for the narrative
that you see in the extended cut i mean
starting with a new opening
and
that new opening is absolutely essential
to pay off the third act and then in
addition to that there are just these
they're moments you know between
characters and transitions from scene to
scene and so by the end of the film
everything adds up
in a way that is very very very
satisfying the locust you're like yes i
get it like i fully fully fully get it
and it's just so cool that universal and
amblin supported this because this is
this is a kind of a
you know a cinema history moment in that
the cast of jurassic park is coming back
30 years later joining the cast of
jurassic world and and
this is not going to happen yeah again
so to have
to have this experience of the movie
that we made shared with audiences is
absolutely thrilling it's awesome it's
it's so cool of universal and emblem
would you like to add anything no bryce
is perfect in every way
i can see it's a very tough day doing
interviews
yeah it's rough out here
[Laughter]
very tough the thing about the extended
cut is not only like as you mentioned
there's just a lot of little scenes but
like there's even the scene at the
beginning where chris is and i forget
the name of the dinosaur where he's
roping i forget do you know the name of
that yeah the one in the big i don't
know that one right neither do i so
let's just say that there's a scene with
chris
roping that dinosaur and there's a
payoff to like in the theatrical cut i'm
like okay well where is the scene going
yeah and there's no payoff and then in
the extended cut i'm like oh wait a
minute this has a huge payoff introduces
a character that's you know critical to
the anyway what i'm basically saying is
people need to watch the extension
good
yeah one of the things and i'm sure you
guys noticed here being in malta is i'm
more impressed with the malta action set
piece
now that i've been to malta and seeing
the roads that are like this thin yes
and i'm like how exactly did the second
unit film this listen naomi schiff i get
i try to give her props every single
time i like sit down with anyone i'm so
obnoxious about it but you know my stunt
double my driving scent double she's a
formula one driver her name is naomi
schiff and every time i like watch that
sequence to know that she actually did
that
i mean drove through there there's that
one moment where
where she drove through scaffolding yeah
the scaffolding the likes nothing on any
side like there's no there's not any
size there's no room so precise yeah and
we're driving with you know right now
you know our drivers are they're experts
and they still had to be like oh let me
back up off this corner a little bit and
that truck not for nothing i tried to
learn how to drive that truck
easy truck to drive
not an easy you know total stick shift
like old rickety night early 1980s i
mean that sequence is to your point uh
just absolutely phenomenal and it was
like fun to pretend it was fun
it was fun to pretend then just like
make some faces because you know her
work in this movie is you know i ca i
can't sing its praises yeah we're
talking like inches on each side inches
truly truly like like it you can't do it
unless you are a formula one driver yeah
and she how old she was like three when
she decided she wanted to be a formula
one yeah right yeah she's been doing it
for a very long time and when we were
shooting i think she was 26 uh-huh
like a true phenomenon like it's
unbelievable yeah i i i will never have
that skill set i mean the stunt doubles
are super human like sarah lachlan who's
who's my devil who did that intense jump
here in malta again and again and again
because that's the thing it's not just
once yeah you guys really have time
you're doing it all day wait you're
you're saying you didn't jump from the
root
back oh no a professional did that
professional did that um
i landed
i landed in a cozy spot
from about this high to there yeah for
the this uh trip they've or they had us
recreate your st the earth i i heard
that and um uh
i'm just gonna say that i have a lot
more respect for
actors after doing this because i had to
do three moves and then
do stuff for the camera at the same time
and i'm like oh how do you do this yes
it's a lot more difficult then and then
you're like and then if you're adding on
like oh and then this emotional beat
happens here oh forget about it i mean i
was like cut can i get another take can
i do that again chris is so good at that
stuff he has such a relationship with
the camera he's someone just in general
he's very like he's he's he's fluent in
movie like he understands what's
happening with the camera he understands
the lenses and what they do and how to
how to interact with them how to make
sure the performance you're giving is
actually captured yes and there are so
many moments of him where you like see
him like like there's a sequence in
malta where he where he like front rolls
down something and then he gets up for a
second and then he takes off and just
like it's like you see you know that
beat yeah
yeah he's good this is the ending
chapter for you um and the ending
chapter of the jurassic world franchise
what do you guys envision or think
universal might want to do with the the
future i mean there is a character
that everyone loved
she happened to play her
we all want to know
who she is where she came from and what
she's going to do tell us everything all
things kayla watts
that's what i just as a fan that's what
i'm really craving honestly i wanna i
wanna see i wanna
i want to see you
[Laughter]
i want to see you
for sure
i'm here you know universal knows my
phone number they do they do very cool
yeah i'm very curious what's going to
happen because obviously a billion
dollar franchise it's not going away
it's a question of what do they do next
yes
yeah on that note i'm just going to say
congratulations extended cuts fantastic
enjoy malta thank you so much
you